hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this is Tamara Jessa tonight I went
and saw Mamma Mia 2 the second one I was
a part of the Mamma Mia nostalgia critic
review I know that it was a pile of
heaping garbage I understand that I
still I went into this wanting it to be
like a fun type of garbage this though
oh no it's so mean I didn't enjoy it
honestly going into this movie I thought
I was really really going to enjoy it
because the trailers were super up my
alley Mary Poppins Ruth Bader Ginsburg
second act crazy rich Asians
welcome to Marwin or whatever it's
called the spy who dumped me dog days I
was into it I was into every single one
of them was like all of these are trashy
cheesy chick flicks and I'm all about
and well a tipper Ruth Bader Ginsberg
that's that's not trashy or cheesy
that's also my audience was crazy into
it I saw the first viewing of Mamma Mia
here we go again at 7 p.m. at a big
theater in Chicago so the first viewing
that I could see is an audience member
we didn't have a pre-screening and the
theater was pretty light there were not
many people but let me tell you
something guys the people who were there
very into this movie that one but what
about the dog Dog Days the audience
members in front of me were crying
already at dog days the trailer for Dog
Days they were crying at least three of
them in front of me
so amazing they know their target
demographic they had him in the bag and
let me just say that those same audience
members loved Mamma Mia here we go again
I was not one of those people though I
will say I really enjoy how they set up
the first film they kind of introduced
what happened in the first because am I
wrong on this there's there's no second
Mamma Mia musical so this was just all
100% created by people who didn't have
anything to do with the writing of
musical Mamma Mia I enjoy the story the
story is like setting up how the Meryl
Streep character like got to where she
was in the first also there's gonna be
crazy spoilers in this because I don't
care you know what I mean
setting up where Meryl Streep was
setting up the three men who could
possibly be the father of Amanda setting
that up I enjoy that story what I don't
enjoy I will say movies that are
theatrically based that have a lot of
singing in them
I genuinely like I don't care about the
singing as much a lot of people like in
lameness let's use that as an example a
lot of people didn't like the vocals in
that and that's what really got them but
that I can take or leave that like
vocals matter little to me if the acting
is okay like if the acting is there I'm
on board
if the acting is not there it's it's a
goddamn disaster I'm gonna tell you
something the acting was not for the
most part I honestly I think that Amanda
Seyfried Seyfried I don't know how to
say laughing but Amanda she was possibly
one of the better actresses some of the
older actors brought in some funniness
and some comedy for the acting but the
main story is about Meryl Streep's
character who in this is a lot younger
played by another a younger actress of
course and I wasn't on board for it I
didn't think the acting was there and
that sucks and it totally took me out of
it and it just wasn't like like funny or
fun and that's totally my opinion
obviously because the people who in
front of you were watching loved it and
they were super here for it and I also
think that that's because this movie is
only for people who have seen them first
this is not in any way for people who
have not seen the first if you've not
seen the first movie this movie is not
for you you can skip this 100 percent I
was lost in a lot of areas and I
shouldn't be this should be a pretty
simple like plotline I feel like and
also to its credit it was but they
weren't like catering to people who who
who missed the first at all so again I
don't know the story of the first so in
the first like five minutes of the story
I just wrote so dot dot Merrill is dead
question mark dot dot dot and then a
song-and-dance number broke out out of
nowhere it was very spontaneous it was
crazy and I just wrote oh my god this is
so ridiculous oh my god oh my god oh my
god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my
god oh my god it keeps getting worse
we're only three minutes in holy shit
oh my god I didn't realize the songs
were gonna be so random oh my god that's
the whole page it's just like a bunch of
oh my god I said I thought it was the
right demographic for this I was wrong
I'm about to be so mean about this movie
during the song numbers there was like
beautiful diversity there was like
somebody dancing in a wheelchair there
was a lot of fun different actors that I
was happy to see and the audience that
was there was loving it so I was missing
something clearly did people like the
first at all and my what am I missing
are the other people that are seeing
it's night just like the true like
diehard fans of Mama Mia's and how is
that what's happening because we can't
tell so Pierce Brosnan is in this and I
know from the first that he wasn't like
the best of vocalists I said I was gonna
do this on Twitter and everyone was like
oh my god just watch out for Pierce
Brosnan terrible singer I was like I was
ready for it but also I wasn't because
I've never seen James Bond hi my name is
Tara chambers I've never seen anything
I've seen Casino Royale
then you find out what young Pierce
Brosnan did and he's a dick and James
Bond would never he would never actually
I don't know was I never seen James Bond
he might there's some really cute
elements to it though there's like a
girl band and I love that I love the
friendship between the three of them
when they're young I love the friendship
between the three of them even though
Meryl is gone it's still really cute
when they're older I love that cher
is in this movie it's just the grandma
share is just always share which is
amazing just beautiful effortless
gorgeous stunning yes I wrote down
though that like shares voice is so deep
and soulful and full and you can tell
like I don't think share is like a
theater girl but like I don't know maybe
she was but you can tell like that genre
a vocalist from like I don't know like
the new genre like the the young Meryl
of the the ladies that are just not
trained to have that like rich deep like
Oh support in their vocals and I don't
know like I don't know I'm a theater kid
I know the hardships of that but you
couldn't really tell the difference how
you see a musical theater film and and
you obviously want to like really look
deep in on vocals like I did that with
beating the Beast this new one but I
guess I didn't do that with I don't like
Sweeney Todd I didn't feel similarly to
like hairspray so this one was a little
lackluster there so the whole thing is
that they're all showing up for the
opening reopening of the hotel but there
was a big storm and it delayed it but it
was like the storm was the villain of
this film and it was pretty lame so it
felt like there was no conflict at all
which made it so much more for fans of
the first like they were just here to
see like some backstory and like a
little bit of like what's happening now
like it's just like kind of catching you
up and showing you what happened before
just like it's like fanservice and it
was not for anyone else to their credit
who is seeing Mamma Mia here we go again
the second one without seeing the first
only Tamra chambers that's the only
person but just so everyone knows it's
not it's not for anyone else I didn't
even see James Bond but seeing Pierce
Brosnan in this even just knowing that
he was James Bond is just kind of like
oh no
buddy oh no I'm gonna say something that
I don't think a lot of people agree with
and I didn't see the first so maybe it's
improved upon in this one I'm like that
I thought Mario's voice was better than
a lot of the other people that I heard
in this movie I heard a lot of people
were saying like oh man Merrill can't
sing Merrill can't take my mama it was
better than some of them I'll tell you
that
and listen I'm not a snob I like Abba
$0.90 he wrote a dancing queen
something-something Savino yeah you can
dance you can jive having the time of
your life see that girl watch that Queen
dig in the dancing queen I don't know
the lyrics I don't know guys I don't
know I saw this because I thought Teen
Titans go was gonna be this weekend and
I wanted to rag on that but alas that's
not till next weekend so we'll see you
then with that thank you so much for
watching I'll see y'all soon keep
dancing you Queens
[Music]